I've been known to have like three hot
dogs with mustard ketchup and jalapenos
and a large coke and some little turds
and maybe Junior Mints
and a pretzel the butter popcorn by like
Extra Butter to where my husband like
yells at me and I put jalapenos on the
passport I like a beer I feel like a
beer and a bit of popcorn but the
popcorn annoys me it's so loud I sound
so boring no no I like to sit towards
the back middle guys I like to see as
far in fact as I can
I hate sitting in the front I usually
sit like fairly close but on an aisle I
like my movie bathroom breaks I always
eat popcorn because you just have to I'm
in the center of the last road that's
the best seat in the house nobody
breathing on me from the back coughing
Oh phew I made popcorn water and I put
sweetener or sugar on my popcorn I love
popcorn I have to stay away from the
swedish fish close to the center as
possible
midway back no candy I usually pop yeah
classic maybe a diet coke popcorn
definitely Twizzlers and you bite the
ends off of the Twizzlers and then you
put it as a straw into your coca-cola
it's just popcorn and Raisinets for me
I'm right in the middle I don't want to
be at the back or at the front you know
I like to be right in the middle to see
it kind of surrounding me but not like
smack dab in the middle however close to
the middle I can possibly do you gotta
get the right sound balance I'm a
focused driven audience member popcorn
and coca-cola classic and I sit not too
close but in the center kind of like in
the middle of everything right in the
middle in the back
I usually sneak food in I'm a hippie you
know so I'll take something like little
organic like granola bar and you know
maybe some cut fruits I'm like a grandma
with my Tupperware and stuff like that
you know but I know that's very noisy of
me I eat popcorn obviously a root beer
and I might get like some Snickers
popcorn the chewy sweet tarts Kit Kat
and a diet coke middle of the row middle
of the just in the middle
second group of seasonings a fertile of
a second group of seating if I can put
my feet up I shut on the oil and I had a
massive big bucket of popcorn
my husband insists on sitting on the
aisle so we are first third on the aisle
nice tea and it's of evenings a nice
glass of red wine because I'm French at
the very back I like to have some
perspective ideally not to have anybody
in front of you we'll just cut off the
head when you come inside the theater on
the right side on the end I always try
to sit as far back as possible and as
close to the middle as possible every
time I go to lose those my friends are
always like no it's that's too close and
I'm like no this is good but you have to
just sit back and just sort of like get
like this so that you're looking up at
the screen and then you put your feet on
it because no one is sitting them even
closer yeah so you put your feet in
between this in the seat cracks like
that looking up and then I get the
popcorn with the cookie dough bites I
usually eat like lots of stuff that's
bad for me
and I think it's from that stupid you
know branding thing they did in the et
Reese's Pieces I will get released
got to do the popcorn sometimes you got
to do that really terrible fake cheese
nachos some sour patch kids and a coke
and then go home and throw up
[Music]
[Music]